eh bien à nouveau bonsoir mesdames pour
sorel moiselle bonsoir messieurs
il est tout particulièrement agréable à
sud-ouest d'être associé au grand prix
de bordeaux d'échec à travers ce grand
débat que notre journal a décidé de
consacrer cette discipline il a paru
utile en effet à stéphane laborde
organisateurs du grand prix et à
nous-mêmes de porter un regard
particulier sur l'évolution de la
pratique du jeu d'échecs
c'est la raison pour laquelle notre
rendez vous de ce soir a pour titre les
échecs de la tradition à la technologie
mais ce soir stéphane laborde n'est pas
avec nous car il a eu un petit ennui de
santé il ya très peu de temps ennuis de
santé qui nous prive donc de sa présence
nous lui souhaitons bien sûr un rapide
rétablissement et nos pensées vont vers
lui car ce grand prix bordeaux d'échec
est avant tout le sien pour parler de
notre sujet et malgré l'absence imprévue
de stéphane quatre intervenants ont été
réunis sur ce plateau
celui là même où les compétitions vont
se dérouler à partir de ce soir
après notre débat ces intervenants je
voulais présente par ordre alphabétique
jalu jean-luc chabanon et maître
international d'échecs nicolas giffard
des maîtres international et écrivain
bonsoir edouard lange et grand maître
international prime au sort et enfin
jacques rosselin et président directeur
général de canal web nos zones sont bien
sûr les vôtres et vous aurez tout le
loisir de leur poser des questions tout
à l'heure avant de commencer la
discussion je voudrais donner deux
chiffres en france cinquante mille
licenciés pratiquent le jeu d'échecs et
font des compétitions par ailleurs une
estimation assez fiable permet de savoir
que 10% de la population française
pratique le jeu d'échecs pour commencer
je souhaiterais que nicolas giffard nous
parle de l'histoire du jeu d'échecs
alors c'était une longue histoire
justement commencé mon micro marche si
silva on pense que les prémices du jeu
c'est pas le jeu comme il est
actuellement mais un jeu qui s'appelait
à l'époque le château ranga donc a été
inventée si on peut dire en inde à peu
près cinq siècles avant jésus-christ aux
confins de la chine par là il n'y a pas
vraiment de certitudes à ce niveau là et
puis ici diriger tout doucement vers
l'europe en passant par la perse les
pays arabes le maghreb et donc l'espagne
avant de venir au xviie siècle les
centres européens d échec c'était paris
londres et madrid
et puis ça s'est ensuite étendu vers
l'europe de l'est on sait le
l'engouement des russes puis les
soviétiques avec tout l'impact politique
qu'ils ont mis pour développer ce jeu
pour se montrer qu'ils étaient les plus
forts les communistes et puis bien
entendu les etats unis se sont mis à
jouer beaucoup pas évidemment les
migrations notamment d'europe de l'est
actuellement l'équipe des états unis je
crois sur six membres d'en avoir quatre
originaires de russie
et donc voilà ça a été un voyage à
partir des confins d'extrême orient et
le pardon
au niveau des règles du jeu donc ça a
commencé que le château grand gars ça se
joue à quatre puis a eu des formes de
jeu qu'ils jouaient aux dés avec le
hasard ont bougé les pièces qui étaient
désignés par le d beaucoup de donc deux
pièces différentes il y avait le vizir
qui se déplaçait beaucoup moins loin que
la dame qui était élancé de la dame est
beaucoup moins mobile il y avait je
crois aussi
l'éléphant à un moment et puis petit à
petit le jeu a ressemblé à celui qu'on
connaît le rock a été inventée
tardivement je crois vers le 14e siècle
où je ne me rappelle plus exactement
et puis voilà on est arrivé maintenant
un jeu tout à fait
harmonieux puisque 140 pays ont adopté
ce soir on joue de la même façon alors
140 pays il ya quelques variantes
régionales vous avez en chine les échecs
chinois sur le plateau duquel il ya une
rivière au milieu par exemple les rois
sont dans des sortes de buts ils peuvent
pas dé sortir d'une petite zone comme ça
comme dans un but
il ya au japon le shogi qui est un jeu
très tactique ou les pièces peuvent
perdus peuvent renaître donc très un jeu
très volatile ou très complexe du point
de vue tactique
et puis j'en oublie il doit y avoir
d'autres variantes régionales
enfin très peu en fait c'est un jeu
impérialistes qui maintenant à
l'engouement de quasiment tous les pays
du monde et il a pris le pas en fait sur
la plupart des autres jeux notamment au
niveau médiatique on parle des échecs
énormément plus que du bridge que des
dames même que du goût qui a pourtant
beaucoup de participants aussi en asie
donc c'est un jeu qui s'est développé
jusqu'à présent sans interruption et
comment l'expliquez-vous sur
développement commence à cela je crois
que les kurdes sont restés un peu à la
traîne c'est dû à l'incroyable harmonie
et du jeu lui même
vous avez 64 cases donc un tout petit
territoire a priori 32 pièces et puis à
partir de ça c'est à dire vraiment
quelque chose de ce n'est pas
impressionnant du tout il ya un
développement incroyablement riche on
sait qu'il y à peu près 10 puissance 120
partie d'échecs possible c'est à dire
plus que de particules dans l'univers ça
veut dire que un joueur d'échecs comme
moi qui ai joué des milliers de parties
de tournois fin 2000 en l'occurrence
j'ai jamais fait deux fois la même
partie est encore jeune et jouer encore
beaucoup plus puisque j'ai fait des
parties amicales et c'est la
caractéristique jeu tout le monde tous
les joueurs passionnés vous diront c'est
extrêmement variés je n'ai jamais connu
la même aventure dans une partie
d'échecs
est-ce que vous avez une estimation du
nombre de joueurs d'échecs fa de nombre
de personnes qui font de la compétition
on a donné les chiffres tout à l'heure
concernant la concernant la france
est-ce que vous avez un chiffre en
europe et dans le monde par exemple dans
le monde je mange je dirais un million
et demi à peu près de compétiteurs et
comment être vous relier vous avez des
journaux
des revues vous échanger les parties
alors l'andra du net tout à l'heure
jusqu'à présent il y avait effectivement
des revues papier
et puis quelques fois pour les grands
événements s'étaient retransmis dans les
grands médias dans les journaux
nationaux par la télévision
éventuellement quand c'était vraiment
avait des championnats du monde
mais avec internet bien entendu tout
change et n'importe quel petit tournoi
maintenant est relié sur un site
internet vous avez les résultats du
tournoi en question avec les partis qui
sont joués qu'on peut télécharger sur
son ordinateur et les regarder
instantanément une fois que le soir de
10 ans 2 du tournoi était ce qu'il y a
beaucoup de joueurs qui est dont c'est
le métier qui ne font que ça qui gagnent
leur vie en jouant j'ai pas beaucoup
la plupart de ceux qui vivent des échecs
vive d'activités parallèles comme donner
des leçons des échecs c'est le plus
fréquent ou autre mais des joueurs vous
visez des échecs vous par exemple ben
moi je donne des cours effectivement
j'ai écrit des bouquins je vais toutes
sortes de choses autour du jouet win
donc c'est votre activité problème en
réalité
merci nicolas giffard jalu que jean-luc
chavanon une question toute simple
pourquoi jouez vous aux échecs
aujourd'hui mais dites nous aussi
pourquoi un beau matin ou un beau soir
d'ailleurs vous avez commencé à jouer je
joue avec jallet notre témoin oui donc
je joue aux échecs actuellement 20 parce
que j'aime j'aime la compétition et et
je suis un con dire j'adore le jeu
d'échecs depuis toujours quoi donc j'ai
j'ai appris très jeune et
et donc petit à petit j'ai progressé et
actuellement je joue en qu'est-ce qui a
fait que vous avez commencé à jouer aux
échecs et pas au poker par exemple ben
j'ai appris quand j'étais très jeune
donc j'ai appris à l'âge de 6 ans votre
environnement familial voulzy a aidé ou
se montrait mon père m'a appris à jouer
aux échecs mais il ne joue pas du tout
et
ce qui s'est passé c'est que c'est que
je me suis retrouvée finalement je suis
originaire de clermont-ferrand je me
suis retrouvé dans une école où il y
avait un petit club d'échecs
donc j'ai joué deux trois petits
tournois j'ai gagné et et ça a continué
après après comme comme ça m'a plu parce
que j'avais des résultats et en plus le
jeu était très sympa j'ai joué de plus
en plus j'ai commencé à gagner des
compétitions nationales et après je me
suis mis à la aux échecs à haut niveau
quoi comment devient ton maître
international puisque tel est votre
titre a donc bah c'était c'était je suis
devenu maître international ya une
dizaine d'années déjà et je suis devenu
maître en faisant ce que l'on appelle
des normes de maître international
c'est-à-dire des performances des
performances pendant des tournois de
d'une dizaine de partis donc en faisant
une certain nombre de points face à face
à des adversaires d'un certain niveau
donc il en faut trois et j'en ai fait
trois donc voila quoi c'est comme ça que
je suis devenu maître est bon donc les
performances sont quand même d'un
certain niveau actuellement et c'est
votre métier aujourd'hui où vous avez
une autre activité professionnelle
disons que c'est mon métier mais bon
évidemment je joue aussi enfin je donne
quelques cours d'échecs dans mon club
pour pour compléter un petit peu quoi
cette activité et après être maître
international quelle est la progression
possible mais disons que la progression
logique c'est grand maître international
et donc pour le devenir il faut
également faire trois normes de grands
maîtres donc actuellement j'en ai j'en
ai une et
je suis en course pour en faire d'autres
donc il faut que je faut que j'attende
les tonga qui se présentent et un
tournoi c'est vous qui décidez d'y
participer ou vous êtes sollicité que
commencer c'est comme pour le tennis par
exemple poussé le même principe
parfois oui c'est à dire que dans
certains tournois on est on a des
invitations
donc on peut appeler ça des tournois
fermés ou d où d open peu importe est
bon en début de saison aussi il faut
faire son planning choisir les tournois
intéressants et tout donc savoir quel
type de tournoi peut convenir à ma
propre progression par rapport à ce que
je recherche c'est tout donc soit je
recherche des adversaires que je connais
beaucoup comme les joueurs français soit
je cherche des joueurs très forts comme
les grands maîtres russes et tout ça et
en fonction du type de travail que j'ai
fait parce que quand on travaille
beaucoup avec ordinateurs ont en quelque
fois on a préparé certain type de
position et on cherche toujours des
adversaires qui peuvent convenir à ce
travail effectué merci avec vous jacques
rosselin nous allons parler de
technologie puisque je le rappelle vous
êtes le patron de canal web
avez vous le sentiment que la pratique
du jeu d'échecs est réellement en train
de se transformer en s'appuyant sur des
technologies nouvelles autrement dit
va-t-on passé de la confrontation entre
deux intelligence humaine entre une
confrontation pour une intelligence
humaine et une intelligence cybernétique
pour répondre à la question très
directement via il ya le philosophe
japonais qui disait que l'histoire
l'histoire était terminé il ya peu de
temps bon ils se trompaient évidemment
en ce qui concerne le jeu d'échecs je
serai peut-être plus pessimistes
effectivement c'est un jeu fini dans
l'âme je fais un fini au sens
mathématique du terme
la mesure où il ya un nombre un nombre
de partis qui est limité donc à peu près
égale d'après ce que j'ai compris à 10
puissance 120 or les machines calcul de
plus en plus rapidement et on peut dire
que donc a priori il est inéluctable que
qu'une machine puisse puisse être
imbattable bon maintenant les enfin
j'imagine que ce sera un débat
des 10 puissance 120 c'est complètement
inimaginables de balayer tout ça
technologiquement vous c'est probable
milan mais nicolas il ya quand même
énormément de choses qui étaient non
mais pourquoi gilles adam 20,0 et donc
comme un suivi de 120 0 c'est vraiment
trop ouais enfin moi il y à il ya 20 ans
j'avais pas de micro devait pas de micro
ordinateurs
donc il ya beaucoup de choses
surprenantes qui peuvent arriver avec
les technologies on pourra faire la
prospective savoir si effectivement il
existe une machine à bataille
c'est vrai que les machines sont plus en
plus puissantes et met en difficulté
quand même le le le plus fascinant
joueur du monde qui comme heydarov là je
suis les machines battent les hommes pas
parce qu'elle balaye tout parce qu'elle
joue comme les hommes mais un peu mieux
sans se fatiguer 113 donc bon alors ça
c'est pour répondre très brièvement à
votre question bon sauf qu'on n'a pas la
réponse si on la donne mais aujourd'hui
il est en théorie les machines sont bat
le meilleur ou les où les meilleurs 2d
des joueurs d'échecs donc mais l'on peut
progresser
oui mais les machines progresse aussi
extrêmement rapidement mais elle limite
le problème des échecs c'est que c'est
pas forcément le défi peut-être pas et
peut-être pas celui là c'est le
finalement sur les échecs c'est un jeu
et qui oppose de deux êtres humains
voilà la base du la règle de la première
règle du jeu d'échecs à mon avis ça doit
être de dire il ya deux personnes autour
d'un échiquier
bon oui absolument les gens se rendent
pas compte que c'est complètement
absurde de faire sans rencontrer une
machine est un être humain c'est comme
si on a vu ça et pourquoi vous
l'acceptez alors c'est parce que ça fait
de la pub ça rapporte de l'argent
les rayons mais simplement qu'ils
fabriquent des micro ordinateurs qui
joue aux échecs paye des joueurs qui se
maintenant se font battre la plupart
même les grands maîtres et ça leur fait
de la pub c'est tout simplement ça mais
ce qui est alors sur la technologie dont
il ya ce débat il ya ce débat là et puis
il ya internet alors c'est à mon avis de
deux sujets un peu différent je pense
que ce qui était ce kit intéressant
d'évoquer sur sur les échecs moi qui ne
connais pas leur je ne suis pas grand
maître international je joue aux échecs
j'ai battu pour la première fois mon
père à l'âge de 35 ans donc c'est vous
dire que je suis beaucoup moins rapide
que que vous il était furieux d'ailleurs
et
il est plus jamais rejoué avec moi
depuis non ce qui est intéressant
d'évoquer à mon avis et les rapports
entre bien sûr la technologie des échecs
vous pourrez peut-être en parlais tout à
l'heure mais les médias et les échecs et
je pense que c'est ça qu'internet va
bouleverser c'est la façon dont les
échecs sont perçues par les gens parce
que finalement les échecs c'est un ça
ressemble beaucoup à un sport avec des
champions avec des stars avec des
figures historiques et tout à l'heure on
va parler d'eux un peu de l'histoire on
l'a évoqué ma famille est des
personnages dans le jeu d'échecs qui
valent bien des marcel cerdan ou des dés
michel platini terre qui ont vraiment
été des grandes figures du jeu d'échecs
qui ont des histoires souvent
passionnantes
humainement est historiquement une
parenthèse c'est que marie george buffet
a admis les échecs comme sport il ya un
mois et puis je crois que il ya le
comité olympique ou plus ou moins enfin
non non le ministère des sports en
france faute de la jeunesse et des
sports a inclus les échecs maintenant
dans son giron ça va changer quoi dans
votre vie quotidienne dans la gestion
des clubs sera facilitée parce que pour
obtenir des subventions c'est plus
facile alors ce que ce que permet
internet dans le s qui va changer dans
la dans la perception et dans la
médiatisation des échecs c'est
qu'internet c'est un c'est un média
communautaire ses terres c'est vraiment
un média qui peut s'adresser à une
communauté extrêmement précises
d'intérêt de la même façon que 1
nous on fait de la télé sur internet en
fait donc on a une émission à canal web
s'appelle diagonale tv qui est fait par
éloi à laquelle participent nicolas
temps en temps et puis c'était également
et puis stéphane laver puis stéphane
laborde en est l'initiateur et 7
cette émission elle n'a pu voir le jour
des ses émissions hebdomadaires la seule
probablement au monde
l'émission des chèques hebdomadaire à la
télévision elle a pu voir le monde le
jour que parce que cette télévision et
diffusé sur internet et internet est un
média qui convient bien à la diffusion
d'informations vers des communautés
d'intérêts précise et très dispersées
géographiquement
donc c'est ça réellement que va changer
internet ce média communautaire va
permettre à l'information sur les échecs
de circuler beaucoup mieux dans des
conditions économique idoine est donc
finalement de donner à ce sport l'espace
médiatique qui lui manquait jusqu'à
présent puisque les médias jusqu'à
présent et notamment la télévision
n'était absolument pas adapté
économiquement à la création d'une
chaîne par exemple sur les échecs 24
heures sur 24 jacques une question elle
existe depuis combien de temps cette
émission cette émission existe quasiment
depuis la naissance de canal web ce que
canal web qui est donc comme je disais
opérateurs de télévision sur internet le
premier d'ailleurs en europe s'est créée
en septembre 98 on a installé nos locaux
à cognac jay pour démarrer le donc à
cognac c'est le lieu pionniers de la
télé et tout de suite j'ai reçu un mail
de stéphane laborde mais vraiment dans
les rayons dans les semaines qui ont
suivi la création de canal web que
stéphane avait parfaitement compris le
ce qu'on faisait et il avait bien
compris que la télévision sur la
télévision allait enfin pouvoir revenir
vers le monde des échecs grâce à la
télévision sur internet donc la première
émission de canal web c'est en fait
diagonale
aujourd'hui on a 80 émission
hebdomadaire mais on se souvient
toujours que la première d'entre elles
c'est c'est sur les échecs
la première historiquement est la
première en audience puisque la la le
top web immat de de canal web
ces diagonales aujourd'hui à peu près
400 mille visiteurs uniques par mois sur
le site de canal web et sur ces quatre
cent mille téléspectateurs unique ou
visiteurs uniques commander sur internet
il y en a un peu moins de 10% ce qui est
énorme qui sont qui se jettent sur
l'émission sur sur les échecs donc entre
30 et quels jours et à carrière alors
les mises il ya plusieurs émissions m'en
fallait mieux les missions fondatrices
qui s'appelle diagonale tv de marianne à
une autre s'appelle la leçon de la
première est une émission qui a lieu le
vendredi soir à 21h qui est donc visible
en direct mail avantages d'internet
si vous n'êtes pas obligé de vous
connecter exactement à l'heure dite pour
l'émission vous pouvez vous connecter
n'importe quand vous avez accès à toutes
les émissions de diagonale enregistré
depuis un an maintenant
qu'ils restent stockés sur le site c'est
ça aussi la halle avantage considérable
de la télévision sur internet c'est
qu'on a accès de la vidéo à la demande à
la télé à la demande quand on en a envie
mais vous financez comment cette
démission par exemple bien cette
émission on a d'abord installer son
audience et on espère trouver assez
rapidement des sponsors sur l'émission
d'ondés des annonceurs on dit dans le
milieu des échecs c'est pas facile parce
que c'est vrai que les annonceurs sont
rares n'y a pas dans les revues suffit
de feuilleter une revue des chèques pour
se rendre compte que les annonceurs ne
sont ne sont pas légion mais c'est un
peu le problème de la poule et l'oeuf
il faut d'abord créer le média créé
cette télévision sur les échecs
diagonale tv pour voir venir peu à peu
des annonceurs que ce soit pas le pilote
microsoft ibm apple qui sont des gens
qui finalement s'intéresse beaucoup à la
communauté des joueurs d'échecs mais par
ailleurs on peut imaginer aussi que
comme dans la télé classique y est pour
certaines émissions de diagonale tv des
formules d'abonnement pour des émissions
plus pointus ou où justement comme les
leçons comme comme des cours kg aquila
seraient seraient des émissions payantes
soit soit par abonnement ou soit à
l'unité merci et loire aux langes comme
l'aurait sans doute fait notre ami
stéphane laborde j'aimerais que vous
nous parliez de votre implication dans
la discipline du jeu d'échecs qui je le
sais est totale et que vous nous
expliquer un petit peu on a commencé à
le dire tout à l'heure mais comment
s'articulent les compétitions par
exemple le grand prix de bordeaux à quoi
sert-il
est ce que c'est une première marche une
troisième marche
j'aimerais que vous nous d'écoliers un
petit peu tout ça alors d'abord parlons
de vous oui alors bon beaucoup de
questions la première chose donc moi
on va commencer par là alors donc j'ai
commencé à jouer aux échecs à l'âge de 4
ans je suis très très joueurs c'est à
dire que je me passionne pour tous les
jeux et j'ai trouvé que le jeu d'échecs
était vraiment la formule 1 des jeux
donc c'est logiquement que j'ai je me
suis spécialisé dans cette discipline
vous aviez les antécédents familiaux non
pas du tout mon père ne joue enfin joue
aux échecs connais les règles du jeu
mais n'est pas un joueur de compétition
mais on est bon on aime jouer dans la
famille ça c'est vrai donc finalement je
suis devenu grand maître international
d'échecs et là ma progression s'est
arrêté non non pas tout à fait non c'est
comme être intéressé en la portant à 20
ans donc c'est c'est venu un peu tard
mais quand je suis devenu grand maître
international j'ai senti un palier je
dirais difficile à améliorer a augmenté
je trouvais moins de motivation est donc
je me suis logiquement tournés vers vers
quelque chose pour rester dans les
échecs quand même mais qui ne soit plus
le jeu en lui-même qui est très très dur
c'est à dire la médiatisation du jeu
donc j'en suis arrivé à rencontrer
stéphane laborde qui m'a parlé de
l'émission diagonale donc j'ai tout de
suite été emballé par le projet puisque
pour moi effectivement comme dit jacques
on sait pas si c'est la cool qui fait
l'oeuf ou la fif et la poule mais une
émission sur le jeu d'échecs ça me
semblait vraiment approprié donc on a
commencé à faire ça avec canal web donc
les sur diagonale qui marche qui marche
actuellement très bien donc les échecs
c'est votre métier vous aussi plus
maintenant
les échecs c'était mon métier maintenant
donc cette r j'étais joueur d'échecs
professionnelle c'est à dire que je ne
faisais que des tournois je gagnais ma
vie en jouant des tournois en juin pour
les clubs
maintenant je joue beaucoup moins je
joue beaucoup moins donc je gagne
beaucoup moins c'est normal donc il y
avait aussi une autre partie il y avait
la partie des tournois d'échecs
donc comment se passe un temps un échec
je suppose que parmi vous il y en a
beaucoup qui n'ont jamais vu un tournoi
il ya trois types de tournois compte
trois ou quatre types disons la majorité
c'est des tournois qu'on appelle open
c'est à dire que chacun est libre de s'y
inscrire donc il ya par exemple un
tournoi à périgueux la gg pas le papier
qui est pendant les vacances de pâques
ça c'est un tournoi open sur trois jours
chacun est libre de s'y inscrire et
d'aller y participer il y en a
énormément ça réunit régulièrement entre
200 500 voire même 1000 joueurs ça se
passe en offrande c'est à dire neuf neuf
affrontements et finalement le meilleur
des neuf partis remporte le tournoi
ça c'est le tournoi que tous les gens
les joueurs de clubs jouent après il ya
les tournois de l'élite
c'est à dire qu'on va pas faire jouer
kasparov parmi 1000 joueurs ça serait
pas logique on fait jouer kasparov
contre les meilleurs joueurs du monde
contre cramique contrevenante contre
karpov et ça on en sélectionne 10 on les
met dans un paquet et tout le monde
rencontre tout le monde maintenant on
arrive aux échecs spectacle qu'est la
troisième type de tournoi qui est ce
grand prix de bordeaux
donc pour les échecs spectacle c'est
différent il ya une mise en scène il ya
du public
il ya des commentaires donc il ya cet
écran de projection géant qui est qui
est derrière qui servira tout à l'heure
la projection des partis et ça c'est ce
que vraiment ce que stéphane laborde a
compris il ya quatre ans et que l'avenir
du jeu d'échecs ne passait pas par des
salles sombres ou par des tournois très
très fermé aux médias ça passerait
simplement par par la médiatisation
absolue et pour ça il faut une belle
salle il faut des bons commentaires
et il faut commencer sur des bonnes
bases donc ici on en est à la quatrième
édition de bordeaux
la première édition il y avait moins de
monde il y avait moins de moyens il y
avait moins de médias maintenant il ya
eu l'apparition du système triton pour
la troisième année une innovation
technologique grâce auquel vous
m'entendez parlé ici dans cette salle et
cette année il ya canal web qui filmera
l'événement en direct
et donc en différé et ça c'est le
tournoi mon temps plein ils sont directs
là enfin il est sur canal web en ce
moment là un d'accord oui d'ailleurs
vous pouvez intervenir sur le chat de
canal web
il ya des personnes qui sont en ce
moment même en train de
de dialoguer avec aux commandes c'est
bastien sylva qui est un maître d'échecs
qui connaît bien les ficelles du métier
et qui explique probablement des choses
le grand prix de bordeaux voilà sa 4ème
édition maintenant va être transmis en
direct sur canal web ainsi que ce grand
débat sud ouest ça c'est vraiment une
innovation majeure puisque c'est
toujours réitéré cette histoire de la
poule qui fait l'oeuf mais ça ça va
intéresser les médias traditionnels
probablement et de toute façon c'est
comme celle médias du futur ça va
marcher ici donc là les tournois
d'échecs sont en train de se développer
grâce à ce genre d'événement qui sont
assez uniques finalement puisque la
dernière fois qu'on a vu ça c'était les
grands prix intel il ya 3 4 3 ou 4 ans
de cela mais c'était pas parti sur de
bonnes bases puisque c'était pas
pérennisés est-ce que je peux poser une
question aux spécialistes des chèques là
ici est ce qu'il ya des des tournois des
grands tournois qui aujourd'hui sont
retransmis à la télévision par exemple
en russie ou en espagne je crois qu'en
espagne on est très très fan du jeu
d'échecs et que certaines télé
retransmettent les matchs
oui l'espagne est connu pour avoir par
exemple pas en 1987 a sévi retransmis
cinq heures de suite en direct la
dernière partie décisive entre kasparov
et karpov et c'était une première c'est
à dire qu'en général on homes ont
diffusé en différé au montage on coupe
les moments non là c'était la vraie
partie en intégralité
alors que les commentateurs donc pendant
cinq heures font un peu de com jean
michel larqué et thierry c'est
d'anticiper sur ce qui va se passer bien
entendu puis arrive à tenir cinq heures
mais parce qu'il ya des l'aide de
palettes graphiques qui permettent de
faire des dessins explicatifs pour
savoir où kasparov entend mettre le
cavalier enfin il ya des croquis qui
sont faits pour expliquer aux gens le
pourquoi de des coûts ça c'est rare mais
le plus spectaculaire en revanche ce
sont les tournois comme ici c'est à dire
à élimination directe en partie rapide
vous allez voir les parties de 25
minutes chaque joueur c'est la cadence
idéal pour qu'à la fois les joueurs
aient le temps de construire de belles
idées belles choses et en même temps que
les spectateurs ne s'ennuie pas parce
que ça bouge toujours n'y a pas de ya
pas de temps mort là pour en revenir
les lois c'est un tournoi un peu de
démonstration là oui tout à fait c'est
un tournoi qui est sympa sans classement
ce n'est pas un tournant c'est
effectivement un temps d'un spectacle
des parties rapides
les joueurs vont s'affronter donc en
partie de 25 minutes avec des
commentaires très simple on s'est basé
sur le foot un modèle qui a marché
thierry roland et jean michel larqué que
seront donc jean luc et nicolas on ne
sait pas qui a tiré roland ni jean
michel larqué mais en tout cas ils vont
être très vivant aux commentaires
puisque les deux joueurs sont très forts
et bien entendu oui il ya une différence
quand même c'est que le les spectacles
au football compte pour du classement
donc ce serait quand même un progrès je
dirais dans la dans l'organisation
mondiale du jeu d'échecs du niveau du
match amical c'est un peu ça quand même
mais si les tournois qui était spectacle
comme ceux ci comptait également pour le
classement ça attirait sans doute
beaucoup plus de deux joueurs ça a été
fait en 94 et 95 pendant deux ans la
firme intel a sponsorisé un circuit
mondial un moscou new york londres et
paris de quatre étapes comme ou yahoo
tennis les étapes du grand chelem
pendant deux ans ça a été fait et
malheureusement ça n'a pas continué
intel et kasparov saison plus ou moins
fâché ça s'est arrêté mais c'est ça
effectivement la formule d'avenir c'est
de créer un circuit comme ça de
d'événements de ce type
alors à quand à quand le circuit
diagonale mais le sûr que le circuit
dyke diagonale on est en train de mettre
en place puisque là c'est la première
étape pour cette année le grand prix de
bordeaux
la deuxième étape c'est dans un mois au
sénat mais bon je serais tenté d'enlever
le mieux physiquement puisque de toute
façon c'est assez suivie depuis le monde
entier puisqu'il sera également
retransmise sur canal web sur diagonale
et sur tous les sites diffuseur donc et
la troisième édition sera à montpellier
en octobre
donc c'est déjà un circuit diagonale qui
est mis en place tout simplement votre
organisation
c'est vous avez une fédération nationale
qui est un peu garantes de l'éthique de
ce que vous organisez qui qui gère un
petit peu ou comment ça se passe
la fédération a beaucoup de soucis il
faut dire il faut gérer des classements
faut gérer
trente mille licenciés en fait il y en a
pas cinquante mille ya trente mille plus
des affiliés donc les bons ça c'est un
détail mais il faut gérer tout ça faut
gérer toutes les compétitions par équipe
tous les dimanches ils sont nombreux ils
ont beaucoup de bonne volonté mais sur
ce genre de tournée spectacle ils sont
pas ils sont pas actuellement pas
présent la preuve c'est que diagonale et
canal web sont les seuls à les organiser
actuellement si la fédération s'il était
mis en aurait déjà beaucoup plus puisque
le succès à mon avis est garantie en
tout cas pour ce type d'événement je
vous propose que nous engager un
dialogue avec vous mesdames et messieurs
avec une toute petite précision il est
18h45 il sera souhaitable qu'on arrête
la rencontre vers 19h30 de façon à
réorganiser un petit peu la salle et
pour commencer le tournoi donc la parole
est à vous il y à des micro baladeur
dans la salle évidemment j'ai une
première question puisqu'il faut tu
relances et les questions il ya eu un
tournoi récemment dont j'ai entendu
parler dans libé qui est un tournoi
organisé entre machines ou entre
logiciels qu'est ce que ça vous inspire
sa nicolas par rapport à la discussion
qu'on a eue tout à l'heure tout un
métier qui fout le corps là moi ça
m'inspire rien de positif parce que si
vous regardez les parties de machines
elles sont toutes assez triste je veux
dire les machines n'ont pas d'intention
spectaculaire à chaque coup elles font
l'état des lieux elle balaye les
possibilités sur cinq ou six coups de
profondeur est comme ça elles peuvent
changer leur fusil d'épaulé de stratégie
autant de fois qu'il ya deux coups dans
la partie donc elles n'ont pas
d'intention harmonieuse comme peuvent la
voir les humains et les hommes qui
prépare ses machines doivent être de
somptueux joueur d'échec quand même non
oui mais effectivement donc les joueurs
qui programme les machines donne
quelques principaux machine pour qu'elle
puisse élaguer les arbres des
possibilités on en a parlé tout à
l'heure les possibilités sont tellement
gigantesques que dans le temps imparti
aux
compétition les machines n'aurait pas le
temps quand même de tout balayer alors
il ya des programmeurs qui font en sorte
que la machine se limite aux coûts les
plus importants mais ce que je voulais
dire c'est que ce qui est beau échec ce
qui est intéressant ce sont les idées
humaine comme le dit jacques tout à
l'heure c'est un peu les hommes écrivent
et les machines corrige les fautes
d'orthographe
c'est un peu ça en fait qui se passe aux
échecs et que malheureusement les
résultats des parties d'échecs sont plus
sanctionnés par les fautes d'orthographe
en fait
disons que le résultat sportif d'une
partie d'échecs c'est ça c'est que si on
fait un mauvais coup eh ben on perd en
général aux échecs et des machines
n'ayant pas de moments d'absence
eh bien elle gagne à cause de ça en fait
c'est l'équivalent de l'écrivain et du
logiciel traitement tech qui corrige
orthographe et autant de différences
winock pas tout à fait puisque
l'écrivain et logiciels qui corrige les
fautes d'orthographe c'est plutôt mettre
un homme et un ordinateur retrouver un
ordinateur contre un ordinateur c'est
pas tout à fait la même chose ça se
rapporteraient plus aux combats de
robots qu'on voit régulièrement à la
télé quinon qui n'ont aucun qui n'ont
aucun intérêt
enfin a priori ces deux machines qui on
sait pas qui a mieux programmer
effectivement à mon avis ça c'est pas
l'avenir du jeu d'échecs
par contre l'homme plus machine contre
sommes plus machine ça c'est plus
intéressant puisque là la créativité est
encore est encore importante
c'est ça qui va faire la différence et
la machine évite les fautes ça mon avis
et ça peut être ça peut être l'évolution
puisqu'on est dans le débat
les échecs rencontre la technologie
c'est-à-dire la machine est à côté
chaque joueur a son écran d'ordinateur
il met la position sur l'écran il gère
son ordinateur
la machine lui donne des variantes et
lui des beats tout un tas d analyse lui
disant qu'elle est à son avis de
meilleurs coûts et le joueur ait choisi
de son libre arbitre
c'est à dire qu'il finit par jouer son
propre coup de même qu' il y avait des
joueurs on a commencé par faire des
courses à pied quand il ya eu la voiture
on a fait des courses automobiles
ça je pense que ça peut s'apparenter à
cette évolution la
oui je voudrais juste faire un petit con
du compte rendu très technique de ce que
peut apporter la machine aux échecs et
de ce que ce qu'elles n'apportent pas
actuellement c'est qu'actuellement donc
donc moi j'utilise de temps en temps des
logiciels pour pour me préparer pour les
tournois mais malheureusement la machine
comment dire à des gros problèmes au
niveau du concept et au niveau des
notions abstraites
c'est à dire aux échecs par exemple il
ya ce qu'on appelle des sacrifices c'est
à dire des déséquilibres de matériel et
donc la programmation de la machine est
sûrement et qu'on dirait basée sur
l'évaluation des positions donc quand
une position en fonction de différents
critères quand une position est à
égalité matérielle elle peut la juger
probablement comme égal si un adversaire
joueur à un pion de plus elle va juger
donc son camp comme le camp en
supériorité malheureusement échec il ya
des sacrifices de pièces il ya des
choses qui font qu'on a moins de
matériel mais les pièces on sent plus
active est bon actuellement les machines
ne sont pas capables souvent de
discerner qui al'avantage dans ce type
de position est bon je pense qu'il ya
encore une bonne dizaine d'années avant
qu'on arrive à des résultats efficaces
dans ce type de domaine et en plus je
pense que c'est quelque chose qui n'est
pas évident au niveau de la
programmation parce que c'est c'est
qu'on dira c'est rentré une idée on sort
des maîtres de la mathématique est
rentré des idées des concepts et c'est
vraiment quelque chose que la machine ne
peut pas faire qu'on ne peut pas
programmer très très facilement
actuellement il faut des joueurs très
forts pour le faire et ça existe déjà
certains logiciels permettent soit de
prendre en compte surtout le matériel
d'autres logiciels permettant que
permettent d'essayer de comment dire
d'avoir quelques concepts quelques idées
abstraites mais actuellement
on en est pas encore un résultat
top quoi exactement donc ça veut dire
que c'est une petite recette que vous
nous donnez là pour battre enfin son son
ordinateur c'est qu'il faut pas hésiter
à faire des sacrifices de pièces
exactement ont d'ailleurs c'est marrant
c'est parce que dans un ouvrage qui a
été écrit une sorte d'encyclopédie où il
ya plein plein de variantes pour
commencer aux échecs dans ce livre là
donc il y avait une variante qui
terminait par net avantage net avantage
blanc et ce qui se passe c'est que enfin
deux variantes le coût proposé par donc
par le livre qui a été vérifié par une
machine était complètement ridicule quoi
parce que les blancs prennent un pion à
l'autre bout de l'échiquier il oublie le
centre ils oublient plein de choses
comment dire fondamentale et l'avantagé
complètement n'est pas blanc quoi
l'avantagé noir entre ce coup c'est
juste un mauvais gagnant la machine n'a
pas tout gagné encore oui alors je vais
juste conclure là dessus c'est que la
déclaration de kasparov après sa défaite
contre dit blue
c'était tout simple c'était pour la
première fois de ma vie j'ai vu que la
quantité pouvait amener de la qualité
donc voilà c'est tout ordinateur
calculant 3 milliards de coût par minute
ça va être dur est-ce que vous pensez
que ça peut faire progresser le joueur
humain
ah mais ça bien entendu mais ça c'est
clair kasparov qui travaillent avec des
ordinateurs depuis des années c'est un
des pionniers de ça a énormément
progressé dans le domaine de la
recherche théorique au niveau des
ouvertures c'était important de la
position de départ en mettant des
ordinateurs et des ordinateurs a tourné
là dessus maintenant kasparov a un peu
le style d'un ordinateur
c'est à dire qu'effectivement jean-luc
citer cet exemple on va prendre l'option
en oubliant le centre et où on leur
jamais joué avant l'ordinateur
maintenant il ya des joueurs qui se
mettent à jouer comme ça mais c'est
l'évolution des idées
justement à propos de kasparov et des
ordinateurs et le jeu sommes plus
ordinateur il ya eu quelque chose
d'absurde qui est arrivé et je voudrais
dire ça pour exprimer que ça gomme un
peu les différents cela la façon de
jouer des ordinateurs 10 on nivelle un
peu les choses parce que kasparov a
affronté un bulgare s'appelle topalov
qui est dans le top 10 mondial
il a gagné en quatre parties il a gagné
4 à 0
comme ça dans des parties normes rapide
à un contre un et puis ensuite les mêmes
trous joueurs trois mois plus tard se
sont affrontés en espagne chacun aidé
d'un ordinateur
résultats des matches sur quatre parties
deux points partout c'est à dire que
l'aide de l'ordinateur à gommer
finalement ce sale et la perse le plus
c'est toute la force de kasparov
justement c'est de faire craquer les
humains en face de lui parce qu'il les
attaques d'une façon très agressive
il n'y a pas un joueur qui fasse plus
pression sur un adversaire même
physiquement quand vous voyez le
grimacer kasparov en face de vous dire
la plupart ils sont déjà battus on
revient vers vous qui n'avez toujours
pas commencé
question vous avez des vrais
spécialistes je vous en prie monsieur
ben moi mais attendez vous avez un micro
qui arrive je pense qu'il n'est pas
branché ce micro mademoiselle attendez
on va réparer votre micro on reviendra
vers vous il y en a un qui est allée
elle est ici posée
ce qui m'intéressait d'or je sais pas
même nos publications c'est fabuleux
les questions ont été posées on a les
bons j'ai découvert les échecs passés
avec ses fans d'abord je ne sais pas non
plus on a un sport donc c'est bien connu
qui socialement dans le grand chose
c'est pas besoin d'équipements en
particulier l'équipe quel jeu d'échecs
dans un sport pas joué par tout le monde
est-ce que vous pensez que le grâce
acacia telit enfin la loi prochaine on
va pouvoir avoir des chars et d'autres
pays en voie développement et c est ce
que tu espères que les rapprocher pas
d'ordre du jour annonce à pâques
développer je pense que c'est surtout
enfin c'est surtout internet lui-même
qui qui qui a tendance à structurer des
communautés comme je disais mondial donc
avec un intérêt intellectuel concentré
mais par contre une très très forte
dispersion géographique est le moyen de
transport interne est donc le réseau
internet pour ça pour structurer ces
communes telle à les faire vivre est
vraiment est vraiment idéal et donc je
pense effectivement que ça va contribuer
à rapprocher des gens qui ont des
centres d'intérêt communs dans tous les
domaines d'ailleurs celui de voir les
sites qui fonctionne bien aujourd'hui
sur internet
ce sont des sites qui justement
structure des communautés autour de
autour de sujets avec des gens qui a
fortement avec des gens qui apportent
leur propre leurs propres informations
poste des pages personnelles sur sur un
certain nombre de domaines et donc ou
communiquent entre eux construisent en
fait finalement leurs propres médias
communautaires à l'intérieur de du
réseau mais c'est sûr que c'est ça va
contribuer au rapprochement en tout cas
alors peut-être pas peut-être pas je ne
suis pas je vais pas faire d'angélisme
en disant que ça va contribuer au
rapprochement nord-sud eu un peu le
problème du rapport cependant sud il est
hélas ce ne sera certainement pas réglé
par internet
malheureusement il faudrait une c'est
plutôt de ça va être réglé par part de
la politique et est plutôt que par
internet mais en revanche c'est sûr que
ça va contribuer à fédérer des gens dans
les communautés ceci dit est juste avant
de sa parole
il ya un paradoxe de l'internet qui fait
qu' il ya des sites qui ont beaucoup de
succès aussi sont les sites locaux
je pense à nos amis de sud ouest la
porte d'entrée
finalement qui marche le mieux sur
internet est la porte d'entrée de
l'information locale parce que
finalement c'est ce qui intéresse
beaucoup les gens et il ya d'ailleurs
des communautés qui peut se structurer
au plan local nous mêmes on voit avec
avec la télé sur internet donc diagonale
par exemple on peut pas faire la même
émission sur les échecs
si on est en france si on est en espagne
aussi en angleterre donc certes il ya un
moyen de communication mondiale certes
il va contribuer à un rapprochement
inter pays puisque les communications au
plus vite mais bon les idiosyncrasies
locales les très fortes spécificités des
cultures locales sont reste très
présente également sur ce média et ce
réseau mondial et justement est-ce que
s'il n'y a pas un petit effet en ce
moment pernicieux qui pour les les
groupements locaux les empêche de se
réunir physiquement je veux dire c'est
un peu comme aux débuts de la télévision
on avait pu au cinéma où on allait moins
au bistro de la paye est écrite et web
est ce qu'il n'ya pas un petit effet à
je pense que c'est donc je pense que
c'est clair je pense que les gens
sortent beaucoup moins depuis qu'à la
télé et les gens se rencontreront moins
physiquement parce qu' internet ça c'est
certain
par exemple lorsque je suis chez moi je
peux je sais qu'à tout moment je peux me
connecter sur un sur un site d'échec
c'est un site de jeux d'ailleurs qui
s'appelle place ait où il y en ad'autres
derche pas faire de la pub
spécifiquement représailles
je sais que systématiquement sont
branchés entre 100 et 200 joueurs qui
attendent que quelqu'un leur propose une
partie car effectivement et de tous les
pays d'ailleurs et
alors deux cent mille joueurs par jour
qui ce qui se succèdent mais le camp
quand je voi sur la liste quand j'arrive
en général il y en a quelques dizaines
qui sont en attente que quelqu'un leur
proposent ils sont répertoriés par
niveau donc il n'y a pas de surprise
donc franchement pour quelqu'un qui aime
jouer aux échecs avec un autre être
humain c'est génial et c'est vrai que ça
ça ça ça va il va y avoir deux effets
d'abord le fait que je vais pouvoir
jouer avec un joueur égyptien devant le
voit plus la grimace de son adversaire
landon alors voilà on voit on voit pas
la grimace de l'adversaire on parle mais
nicolas et et loire et chabanon j'ai
oublié ton prénom savent très bien que
la pression ne s'exerce pas forcément
uniquement physiquement et elle s'exerce
parfois par la rapide la rapidité du
coup donc quelqu'un qui ripostent
rapidement et pas et effrayant et aussi
parfois par la violence de la tacc donc
la violence de la taxe a peut être aussi
très très paralysant pour le pour
quelqu'un et c'est même parfois plus
impressionnant dans l'aviron ne voit pas
l'adversaire on est en aveugle et on
l'aimé on essaye de l'imaginer de
l'autre côté comme ça du réseau je crois
que ça ça remplace pas ça s'ajoute c'est
une forme différente mais ça remplace
pas ça remplace pas ça remplaçant et vue
on en est au début alors tout le monde
est fasciné bien qu'en france en une
minute elle déjà ont joué sur minitel
mais dans les autres pays ils sont
complètement fan absa mais on va voir
comme nous on a vu pour le cinéma ou
pour d'autres choses ou pour les stades
de foot aussi le retour des gens qui
ressortent de chez eux après avoir fait
joujou avec la machine
et puis je crois que l'essentiel
finalement pour nous tous autour de
cette table c'est le développement du
jeu d'échecs et sa médiatisation
or internet contribue à ça moi j'ai
jamais autant joué aux échecs que depuis
que je suis abonné internet est alors du
coup on joue chez soi contre des
adversaires étrangers
mais du coup ça incite à aller à des
tournois comme ici bon j'ai fait 600
morts d'aujourd'hui pour venir voir ce
tournoi ce que je ne sais que je
jamais fait de ma vie c'est la première
fois que je vois un tournoi j'achète
plus d'échiquier qu'avant j'ai acheté
une pendule donc je fais marcher
l'économie des échecs mais est
finalement c'est internet qui a été la
muse de danse et ça m'a remis aux échecs
penser que ça fait progresser le nombre
d'adeptes
très sale c'est un outil qui est fait
savoir ce qu'ils prennent c'est
peut-être juste parce que pour quand on
veut jouer aux échecs et qu'on a
vraiment à portée de clavier chez soi
deux cents joueurs dont certains sont
probablement de votre niveau qui disent
bon bah je suis qu'il met d'ailleurs
quand on est en bleu ça veut dire qu'on
n'est pas bon quand on est en rouge on
est très bon et c'est donc vous vous
êtes moins complexés on peut c'est vrai
comme vous le voyez pas il n'y a pas
cette cette pression intimidante de
l'être humain qui parfois pose problème
je vous rappelle que sur le minitel là
les personnes qui commandait des des
produits à la redoute la plupart c'est
parce qu'il n'aimait pas le faire par
téléphone et parce qu'ils étaient
timides au téléphone pour commander par
téléphone
donc ça peut désinhibé pas mal et et ça
sert vraiment le jeu d'échecs
monsieur avec ou sans micro et l'isi
m'entendais la halte reviens je
m'appelle dominique fabry je suis de
périgueux et je voudrais m'adresser à il
va par contre parler bien dedans
en fait elles ou que quand tu parles de
palier que tu te retrouvais dans un
palier à franchir et qui justement c'est
ce qui t'as des motivés parce que tu te
sentais pas capable est ce que ça veut
vouloir dire ces moments temps ciel et
est ce que c'est des pages de déchets
que continuellement oui alors
effectivement il ya eu des paliers tout
au long de la progression donc un palier
supplémentaire aurait pas dû me faire
peur mais passe et déjà j'avais déjà 17
ans d'échecs derrière moi ça commence à
faire long pour un jeu qui ont certes
est illimité ou presque mais 17 ans a
joué aux échecs c'est très long et ça ça
force à se poser des questions surtout
quand il ya des opportunités
qui se présente de rester dans les
échecs et d'être sur un domaine qui me
passionne également qui est qui et
l'informatique
le potentiel
je ne sais pas si je l'avais pour
devenir plus fort plus fort que ce que
je suis maintenant à priori en
travaillant plus sûr je serais devenu
plus fort je sais pas jusqu'où jours a
été je le saurai prendront jamais mais
c'est un choix que j'ai pris 100 ans
sans regret iti fou pour revenir sur les
devants de la scène
pour l'instant c'est définitif d'accord
pour l'instant j'ai une question alors à
eloyes quand on est ce qu'on peut
décider de s'arrêter pendant pendant
deux ans de jouer de faire de la télé
sur internet de sur les échecs et puis
tout à coup au bout de deux ans dire
tiens je me remets est ce que est ce que
est ce que c'est possible ça pour un
point sportif
comme vous oui il ya déjà eu des
exemples par exemple enrique making qui
a raté les échecs bon qui était qui
faisait partie de témoin hier joueurs
mondiaux qui arrêtait de jouer aux
échecs pendant deux ans ou cinq ans
enfin une pendant une longue période je
ne sais pas exactement
et à son retour il était clairement
beaucoup moins forts ils n'arrivaient
plus au top mondial
on a un autre exemple qui est gata
kamsky qui était numéro 2 ou 3 mondial
qui a arrêté pendant un an et ha ça fait
éliminer du premier au premier tour du
championnat du monde
donc effectivement on peut revenir toute
façon on peut toujours prendre du
plaisir à jouer on jouera moins bien au
retour mois pour moi c'est une certitude
je sais pas ce qu'en pense jean luc qui
qui est maître international aegan
jean-luc ouais ouais non moi je suis
tout à fait d'accord mais oui mais bon
quelque fois ça fait plaisir de voir les
joueurs revenir comme fischer qui était
revenu en 92 20 ans après contre pour
jouer son match contre boris spassky et
par exemple enfin j'aimerais bien qu'ils
reviennent encore peut-être en 2002 pour
jouer peut-être contre kharkov quel âge
at-il fischer fischer je crois qu'il a
50 57 ans je dirais je pense qu'
aujourd'hui que je sais pas dans quelle
est la première qualité d'un joueur
d'échecs
donc oui parce que je voulais dit aussi
donc au bon vieux fait parler de ça mais
c'est je pense que ça va être utile ou
par rapport au débat c'est que je pense
que les qualités d'un joueur d'échecs
sont aussi les qualités de quelqu'un qui
qui qui est souvent sur internet ou qui
toujours accès à l'informatique je pense
que pour bien jouer aux échecs il faut
être capable d'assimiler beaucoup
d'informations dans un temps assez assez
limité donc avoir une mettre assez
logique et en même temps faire partie
âprement y avoir beaucoup de créativité
avoir un esprit assez inventif et tout
est donc c'est pour ça que finalement
les gens qui y vont souvent qu'ils ont
l'habitude de manipuler des ordinateurs
peuvent être attirés à un moment de leur
vie par les échecs et le contraire
également dans le cas des lois et le cas
idéal quoi le cas typique du joueur
d'échecs qui qui s'intéressent jeu j'ai
beaucoup d'amis grand maître tout qui
qui qui adore l'informatique et qui
veulent comprendre comment tous tous les
logiciels toutes les nouvelles
technologies tout fonctionne quoi dire
c'est c'est vraiment je pense qu'il ya
un point commun très très très important
nicolas giffard veut travailler sur
cette question je crois qu'il faut une
bonne mémoire visuelle
il faut ce qu'il faut une intelligence
il faut avoir du sang-froid hors normes
n'ont pas du tout sinon c'est une forme
d'intelligence comme il y en a beaucoup
d'autres
il faut surtout vouloir gagner je crois
que il faut là il faut être compétiteur
dans l'âme uns détesté père adoré la
victoire et d'un point de vue technique
par la mémoire visuelle non je vois pas
vraiment de qualité spécifique aux
joueurs d'échecs peut-être là la volonté
de perfectionniste de chercher vraiment
le meilleur coût je dirais avoir une
espèce de l'exigence intellectuelle et
loi oui les qualités pour être un bon
joueur d'échecs
moi j'ai toujours pensé que c'était le
travail toujours le travail
donc j'en ai pas fait assez de toute
évidence et jean-luc non plus et c'est
bien dommage en france on n'est pas très
travailleur à part un jeu à lautier
etienne bacrot qui sont nos deux
meilleurs espoirs
enfin un peu dur avec toi même ce soir
votre choix
il ya quand même un mystère sur sur le
jeu d'échecs bon on peut aimer
l'informatique
on peut aimer l'internet et être très
piètre joueur d'échecs ce qu est ce qu
est ce qui est mon cas il ya quand même
il ya quand même quelque chose et quand
même une qualité assez mystérieuse qui
fait qu on trouve de très bons joueurs
comme comme eloi
très jeune enfin toi même tu as dit que
tu avais commencé très jeune il lie à ce
jeune prodige là dont on parle là en ce
moment qui est un qui est tout jeune je
crois qu'il ya 8 ans 9 ans qui a fait
une performance de grands maîtres je ne
sais quoi pas bon donc il ya s'étonnant
par exemple de voir des gosses qui
jouent très très bien comme ça aux
échecs ya quand même quelque chose de
mystérieux là d'un demi-cent deux
mystérieux disons que pour ce qui est
exceptionnel peut-être que là je dirais
moi personnellement que ça toucherait
plus être dans de plus tôt dans le
domaine de la psychologie
c'est à dire que on pourrait on pourrait
déceler en fonction d'eux mêmes à partir
d'éléments physiologiques de comment le
cerveau est construit comment comment
fonctionne que peut-être certaines une
certaine candeur partie de l'hémisphère
du cerveau fonctionne mieux chez les
joueurs d'échecs que chez chez d'autres
individus d'ailleurs il ya un livre du
siècle dernier qui a été écrit par cars
par le psychologue binet qui parle de la
psychologie des joueurs d'échecs dans
lequel il explique un petit peu que il
prend différents exemples sur la vision
est rien à voir avec l'informatique donc
non ça n'a rien à voir mais il n'empêche
que que bon les qualités que j'ai dit
tout à l'heure existé et que les joueurs
d'échecs
ceux des bosses on donne souvent de bons
informaticiens aussi je pense juste une
question sur fisher en fait bon nous
évidemment on adorerait à diagonale tv
le lavoir sur le plateau et et ça sera
sans doute ça arrivera sans doute un
jour je pense simplement il est pas
privé de sortie de son pays il est je
crois qu'il peut pas sortir entre et
qu'ils ne puissent plus rentrer aux
états unis mais est-ce qu'il a le droit
de sortir de ce congrès il est en gris
il a le droit de sortir de hongrie je
pense oui mais peut-être que peut-être
qu'il peut pas aller dans certains pays
parce qu'il est poursuivi par une police
internationale qu'elles resteront en
dehors de vos mains disons que je pense
que
il a eu des problèmes très sérieux il ya
quelques années avec
avec le gouvernement américain et oui il
a brûlé un drapeau américain ce qui est
très mal vu là bas et il a enfreint
l'embargo contre la yougoslavie
parce qu'il a joué son match contre
spassky et au monténégro et c'était
interdit de faire sa question
oui j'aimerais faire une remarque sur
les ordinateurs et l'apport que ça que
ça mais pour les joueurs et bon joueur
d'échecs et j'aimerais souligner quand
même une chose c'est que les très bons
joueurs qui utilisent les ordinateurs
ont une base de données très importantes
ils peuvent sélectionner les meilleurs
coups voire les variantes etc etc
pour moi qui suis un simple amateur
enfin je joue en club mais je suis un
simple amateur je n'utilise pas ça et
c'est un peu comme la remarque vous avez
fait avec le coureur à pied et la
voiture pour ma part je reste
courard à pied et les bons joueurs
prennent la voiture alors à titre
personnel je dois quand même dire que je
n'aime pas forcément jouer contre des
très bons joueurs
tout simplement parce que quand on
arrive au 20e coup 25e 25e coup que je
réfléchi pendant 15 minutes 20 minutes
sur un coup et est en fait je passe
beaucoup de temps là-dessus alors que le
bon joueur lui il va tout de suite
savoir quelle est la bonne réponse alors
à cela j'aimerais quand même rappeler
une proposition de fisher qui était de
tirer au sort au début de la partie
la position des pièces alors bon
évidemment ça serait pas facile à mettre
en place mais pourquoi pas pourquoi est
ce que ça pourrait pas être une solution
à cela
oui alors moi je pense que l'essentiel
au jeu d'échec c'est de s'amuser donc
effectivement joué contre kasparov sa
zéro intérêt ni pour lui ni pour vous ce
qu'il faut c'est juin joueurs du même
niveau ou le score final sera l'ordre de
6,4 5,5 ou en tout cas ce un petit
niveau ce qui est important c'est
d'avoir un adversaire qu'on peut battre
effectivement suite à un niveau plus
élevé on arrive dans les sphères de la
compétition
et là on se fait des défis toujours
nouveau et ainsi de suite
bon sinon pour leur en donne chef
puisque c'est comme ça que ça s'appelle
où on place les pièces sur des cases
aléatoire ça augmentera simplement la
masse de travail il faudra multiplier
par le nombre de possibilités de
combinaisons et vous serez toujours dans
les mêmes soucis
donc ça c'est pas une solution mais je
crois qu'il faut pas exagérer
l'importance des premiers coups
d'ouverture c'est pas comme ça qu une
partie d'échecs se gagne ou se perd en
général c'est très très rare le
pourcentage de partis qui se décident
avant le 20e coup en fait les gens qui
connaissent les ouvertures
ils connaissent aussi toutes les autres
domaines du jeu mieux que l'amateur en
fait et c'est pas parce que il connaît
par coeur une certaine ouverture qui va
vous battre parce que si vous vous
connaissez pas la théorie de manière
vous n'allez pas suivre le fil de la
théorie est donc le joueur expérimenté
pourra pas se servir de ses
connaissances livresques
on parle une ouverture c'est quand même
important vous avez d'ailleurs écrit un
ouvrage sur le sujet pour justement
éviter que des amateurs et et et ou
amateurs éclairés face de grosses
bourdes
vous m'avez montré tout à l'heure un
problème ou karpov dès l'ouverture avait
fait une grosse connerie donc je pense
que c'est une partie peut quand même se
perdent sur une ouverture même quand on
est grand grand grand maître
international oui j'ai montré ça parce
que c'était effectivement impressionnant
de voir car peuvent faire une aussi
grosse bourde
mais ce que je veux dire c'est qu'on
peut se contenter de premier coup assez
modeste dès l'instant qu'on ne crée pas
un dommage trop grave dans sa position
va pas perdre la partie si on donne pas
un pion sans raison si on ne concède pas
trop d' espaces
si on joue des coups je vais simplement
raisonnable on peut très bien et battre
quelqu'un est le plus fort que soi
jean-luc chavanon vous êtes d'accord
avec nicolas giffard oui je pense que le
problème ne se pose pas en train amateur
et un professionnel disons que le
problème se pose plutôt entre
professionnels eux-mêmes c'est qu'il
arrive quelquefois qu'au top niveau
une partie se gagne à l'avance et ça
c'est vrai que c'est dommage parce qu'on
peut pas parler de deux coups magiques
ou des deux concepts fantastique tout et
tout et trouvait à la maison mais ans
quand un amateur joue avec un
professionnel hyper parce qu'il est
facile et plus faibles et pas parce que
la professionnelle connaît beaucoup de
choses je pense que la question et
enfin il faudrait travailler cette
question mais c'est pas le cas en tout
cas donc si j'ai bien compris pour
battre une machine faut faire des
sacrifices de pièces faire des coups
complètement dingue qui vont la
surprendre alors pour battre quelqu'un
de son niveau il faut jouer très en
retrait faire attention faire des coups
très prudent et finalement pas faire
trop de bêtises et à cela on a des
chances de battre un autre être humain
même plus fort que soi c'est vrai
qu'actuellement c'est peut-être un peu
ça actuellement c'est vrai que les êtres
humains entre eux ont tendance à jouer
très timoré jouer assez a bien joué très
très solide un petit peu comme on
jouerait contre une machine et contre le
oui sauf kasparov et et moi et et les
machines par contre il faut il faut leur
trouver des idées des concepts très très
abstraite et là c'est le succès garanti
par exemple actuellement si vous la
conseille c'est que pour jeu contre une
machine vous jouez des positions très
très fermé où les manoeuvres sont à très
long terme et la machine est incapable
de savoir de trouver la solution pour
améliorer sa position
ça c'est vraiment quelque chose de vrai
que j'ai un conseil à donner simplement
c'est ne jouais pas contre une machine
jouer entre joueurs humains
c'est beaucoup plus intéressant oui la
question avait un autre aspect celui des
bases de données donc la très vite
puisque puisqu'on a plus on n'aura pas
trop le temps je voudrais rentrer
retransmettre un peu l'évolution de des
échecs sur internet
au début c'était juste le téléchargement
de partie c'est à dire on pouvait avoir
les parties jouées à londres à new york
et où on veut donc dans la journée dans
la semaine
ensuite ça a été les informations après
le jeu en direct
donc maintenant on est arrivé à la
formation de base de données
gigantesques qui sont évidemment
gouaille de bol ils ont améliorable au
jour le jour puisque tous les jours il
ya des nouvelles parties qui circulent
sur internet
donc maintenant la base que avec
laquelle je travaille quand j'y
travaille
elle fait un million cinq cent mille
partie ce qui est considérable donc
après on peut demander kasparov dans
l'east indienne en 87
avec ce plan là et il va trouver deux
trois parties ce qui est quand même un
outil de travail très
performant et ça s'améliore au niveau de
jeu de toute façon c'est indiscutable
que ce soit dans ce domaine là dans le
domaine de la préparation ou dans le
domaine de l'analyse de l'ordinateur les
échecs ont énormément progressé et quoi
qu'on dise nicolas je dis pas que ça ne
permet pas de faire des progrès mais
c'est le jeu contre la machine intérêts
en revanche quand vous jouez une partie
d'échecs
vous rentrez chez vous vous la saisie
c'est dans votre ordinateur qui donnera
son avis hélas la vie sera intéressant
par exemple j'ai fait ça pour le
week-end dernier joue une partie je
croyais la partie s'était déroulée
normalement or mon adversaire et moi
tous les dons avons eu un aveuglement
il pouvait me capturer un cavalier ni
lui ni moi n'avons vu question oui
monsieur
oui j'ai désiré mais aussi pas c'est pas
bon si si c'est bon je parle assez fort
très bien mais parler à monsieur
monsieur moi ça me gauche a parlé tout à
l'heure du plaisir de jouer aux échecs
je rejoins entièrement je pose une
question dans la foulée est-ce que vous
grand maître vous considérez que
certaines parties
le haut niveau peuvent être assimilés à
des oeuvres d'art oui mon père est
peintre j'ai été élevé dans un milieu
artistique
malheureusement ou heureusement enfin je
ne sais pas j'ai pas une énorme
sensibilité pour les belles parties je
suis plutôt impressionné par le
l'exploitent disons technique d'une
combinaison qui a été calculée à l'avant
sans fin par le disons par la force du
coup et non pas par la beauté du coup ce
qui c'est ça qui me qui m'impressionne
le plus quand je vois un beau coup
disons pour la partie c'est du même
ordre pour moi la partie c'est plutôt
une succession de coups c'est à dire je
la vois plutôt sur un côté géographique
que sur un côté historique
bon effectivement mon côté artistique et
pas et pas à son top je me rends bien
compte
autre question il ya oui je vous en prie
monsieur oui vous allez paris bien dans
le micro s'il vous plaît dites un
certain nombre à l'art
d'âge pour topten internet dans les
échecs dans le domaine des échecs qui
répond non non il n'y a pas de limite
d'âge actuellement il ya monsieur coach
neu peut-être vous m'avez entendu parler
qui a 68 ans et qui est numéro 12
mondiale je crois 12 entre 12 et 15
mondial je me rappelais plus exactement
évidemment c'est l'exception mais
l'intérêt du jeu d'échecs et qu'il ya
une palette d'âge énorme on parlait d'un
joueur de 8 ans très fort et il ya donc
des joueurs très âgées qui sont encore
d'un niveau étonnant il ya eu par
exemple aussi smith l'ofs
en 83 il avait 62 ans
il a affronté kasparov en finale des
candidats aux championnats du monde donc
il était au niveau du top 3 cette fois
là à 60 donc j'ai dit soixante deux ans
ouais je suis pas entièrement d'accord
mais disons que c'est vrai que la
différence par rapport à d'autres sports
c'est que un professionnel
comment dire régresse beaucoup plus
lentement que dans d'autres disciplines
c'est bon c'est vrai que corchia il ya
un très fort joueur et il joue toujours
un niveau exceptionnel mais le fait est
que lorsqu'il joue l'échoppé a du monde
et tout ça ils n'arrivent pas à se
qualifier ou où il passe pas il passe
pas toutes les étapes quoi et puis smith
l'ofs
il a perdu quoi le virer mais dans le
dans le top ten justement puisque c'est
l'expression employée par par monsieur
est ce que vous pouvez nous décrire un
peu le tir les premiers il n'ya pas il
n'y a pas une corrélation directe entre
l'âge et la place des gens dans le top
ten mondial
non il n'y a aucune différence c'est à
dire que joueur oui c'est très ouvert où
il c'est vrai que bon disons que l'âge
l'âge idéal est situé entre 25 et 40 ans
à peu près je pense c'est mieux que dans
les autres disciplines sportives c'est
déjà un plus on sait que bon on n'a pas
d'eau on n'a pas les problèmes de
reconversion qu'on les footballeurs ou
enfin je veux dire c'est beaucoup plus
intéressant pour planifier sa carrière
et
et ça peut ça peut même aller beaucoup
plus loin quoi donc c'est ce qui est
intéressant dans les échecs
sinon il ya aussi des jeunes génies
qu'on a des joueurs très jeunes qui qui
qui joue à un niveau excellent mais moi
j'aurai une remarque encore là dessus
c'est que le top 10 mondial n'a pas
bougé depuis des années c'est à dire que
les joueurs qui sont arrivés n'en
sortent plus donc en fait aux échecs
quand on kasparov par exemple les
champions du monde depuis 15 ans 15 ans
je ne sais pas si vous imaginez dans une
autre discipline un champion du monde
pendant 15 ans c'est totalement
inconcevable
et effectivement le top 10 ne bouge pas
c'est à dire que aux échecs quand on y
est on y reste ça c'est à mon avis une
caractéristique voilà je m y ait un
petit bémol c'est l'écho il ya 20 ans 19
ans est morose et vie tchô 6,22 s'en
sortiront plus nicolas ils sont dans les
10 meilleurs mondiaux il on passerait
donc ils ont injecté deux autres oui
justement parlons-en quelques et quelles
sont les perspectives là qui va dominer
demain kasparov d'accord mais quinze ans
d'accord qui va on n'imagine pas
déboulonné dans les prochaines années à
venir
j'ai pas menacées actuellement non et ce
d'autant plus que depuis trois ans il
serrait investi complètement dans le jeu
lui-même la technique avant il se
dispersaient dans l'organisation et là
depuis deux ans après la défaite
d'ailleurs contre 10 pour blue il s'est
remis à vouloir battre tout le monde et
il y réussit oui il avait wiba kasparov
a une avance énorme
il suffit de savoir que il a été
champion du monde à 23 ans pour battre
karpov à cette époque là il fallait
vraiment en vouloir
ça veut dire qu'il a travaillé à mon
avis entre de l'âge de 10 ans jusqu'à
l'âge de 21 22 ans 8 à 12 heures par
jour avec des grands maîtres confirmés
donc avec un entraînement pareil quand
on sait qu'aux échecs maintenant les
joueurs travaillent moins c'est à dire
je sais pas pourquoi mais on travaille
moins qu'avant on est moins rigoureux
parce que peut-être il ya plus ce
système soviétique qui formait des
champions
un bon temps du système soviétique
maintenant les joueurs sont enfin
kasparov mahler indéboulonnable il a
vraiment beaucoup trop d'avancé beaucoup
beaucoup trop et je le vois mal se faire
battre dans les cinq six années à venir
c'est son objectif actuel il veut que
son fils le voit champion du monde et
comprennent qu'il est champion du monde
donc c'est sa nouvelle motivation
puisque effectivement kasparov a quand
même gagné tout ce qu'ils avaient a
gagné son fils doit avoir deux ans ah
oui
jean-luc c'est votre avait aussi à jouer
il va jouer dans deux ans disons que
j'aimerais bien qu'ils aient un nouveau
champion du monde
mais bon de toute façon actuellement
c'est clair que peut-être qu'il faut de
toute façon la rigueur soviétique donc
c'est probablement un russe qui pourrait
prendre la place
il se trouve que la psychologie de
beaucoup de prétendants
nul n'est pas adéquat comment dire il
faut avoir il faut être un tueur d'une
certaine manière et donc certains
joueurs ne le sont pas et est
actuellement bon je dirais qu'il ya deux
trois candidats potentiels pour battre
kasparov donc là actuellement j'entends
parler d'un match entre kasparov et
krainik qui pourrait éventuellement
avoir lieu l'année proche en octobre en
octobre cette année à londres et krainik
quand même peu peut battre kasparov je
ne sais pas je sais pas les pourcentages
de chance mais il pourquoi pas quand je
dirais actuellement il est toujours très
très sérieux très élevé à un style très
solide c'est un adversaire que kasparov
n'a pas rencontré dans ces derniers
matches il a rencontré des joueurs qui
étaient des joueurs 2e cat et qui
attaque et beaucoup là il va jouer
contre un joueur qui n'attaque pas
qu'ils jouent très très solide qui
attaquent comment dire en iran en
puissance disons et la surprise pourrait
peut arriver mais bon kasparov de toute
façon est encore favori mais ça qu'on
dira sa fraîcheur de deux jouent aux
échecs va probablement fin ça va ça va
oui ça va c'est mousse et auteur quoi
lire il peut pas tenir un tel niveau xxl
et ça fait 15 ans donc c'est
probablement la fin d'une certaine
manière
question oui monsieur or viendra vous
après je vous en prie je vous en prie
je crois qu'on vient de vous le dire il
voudrait que son fils le voit champion
du monde et son fils à deux ans donc les
machines à laver ou enfin non à moins
que vous ayez une autre réponse non
c'est celle là monsieur je ne regarde
pas trop la télé je n'ai pas canal web
est par contre lee sud-ouest et je
serais content qu'il y ait des parties
d'échecs commenté dans sud ouest
houda fut président je suis actuellement
actuellement je crois que d'ici dimanche
il ya un problème mais bon les problèmes
ça m'intéresse pas trop non plus ce que
je voudrais c'est des parties le
champion français éventuellement de
kasparov même à la limite commenté
comment on voit des fois dans d'autres
journaux écoutez j'enregistre votre
votre demande et vous n'êtes pas le
premier à la formuler mais on revient
aux communautés d'intérêts qui est
qu'est ce qu'elle en tout cas nous on
peut fournir à sud ouest si le vol une
barre à 6 commenter toutes les semaines
un diagonale puisqu'on en recommande une
toutes les semaines donc on n'a plus
qu'à la grecque par écrit dans sud ouest
et jacques va vous encourager à acheter
un micro et à regarder canal web a
acheté sud ouest dès qu'il y aura plus
de parties commentées dedans question
oui je voudrais revenir un petit peu à
ce qui a été dit tout à l'heure là parce
que contrairement à ce que vous disiez
comme quoi le jeu d'échecs se
développera auprès du plus grand public
s'il est médiatisée entre autres je
pense que de toute façon pour assister à
ce genre de manifestations il faut déjà
connaître le jeu d'échec puisque alors
que pour par exemple un match de foot on
a vite fait de comprendre les règles
puisque envoyer le ballon dans la cage
adverse alors qu'ici si on ne connaît
pas
la marche des pièces il difficile
d'apprécier un tournoi tel que celui qui
va se dérouler ce soir
donc je pense que il est nécessaire de
développer
certes ce genre de manifestation
d'ailleurs je suis le premier à me
réjouir qu il y ait ce genre de chose
d'ailleurs on vient de blois on est une
dizaine un groupe de 10 à venir de blois
envoyé spécialement pour voir ça mais je
pense
il est nécessaire aussi de développer le
jeu d'échecs l'apprentissage du jeu
d'échecs auprès de tous alors je
comprends je suis d'accord aussi et j'ai
pris note que en effet il y avait une
nouvelle émission la leçon qui permet
justement de d'apprendre à jouer mais je
crois aussi que en france on doit être
quatre ou cinq millions d'internautes ou
est connecté sur internet donc ça fait
ça représente moins de 10% de la
population
alors c'est vrai que ça touche une
partie de joueurs qui sont deux
personnes qui sont passionnés qui aiment
ça écoutez vous c'est à mon sens c'est
une très bonne question et je pense elle
a posé mais vous méritez de le faire en
clôture de ce de ce grand débat sud
ouest alors messieurs comment le comment
le nombre de pratiquants petit
l'augmenter comment peut-on intéresser
davantage les gens au jeu d'échec même
si la population qui le pratique n'est
pas négligeable
je crois qu'il ya avant tout c'est dans
les écoles que les échecs ça freine
actuellement il ya énormément de
développement justement de des jeunes
joueurs de compétition en nombre et bien
entendu pour revenir
en dehors de ça au fait qu'on puisse pas
apprécier ce genre de tournoi sans
connaître les échecs
vous allez voir que avec les
commentaires la tension démagogie oui
non on va pas apprendre techniquement
les échecs ce soir aux gens qui
connaissent vraiment rien pas les règles
du jeu
bien qu' il n'est pas difficile de voir
comment bouger un cavalier wintour
mais la simple tension nerveuse les
enjeux qu'on va voir sur cette scène
c'est un drame qui se noue et qui plaît
à tout le monde
je connais beaucoup de gens qui
connaissent rien aux échecs qui ont
énormément apprécié une époque et u2 à
paris première des émissions ou montrer
des partis comme ça se joue à
élimination directe il ya une espèce
d'émotion qui se dégage même sans rien
connaître de la technique je pense je
pense que il ya deux façons de regarder
les échecs vous avez quand vous regardez
c'est comme pour un match de foot au
contraire je continue à soutenir la
comparaison
je pense que moi j'y connais rien au
foot je connais les règles mais j'y
connais rien et donc je sais que si un
professionnel du foot ou un type de
compétition qui regardent le match en
main en coin il va voir 150 truc il va
comprendre 150 truc auquel moi je ne
vais rien comprendre
donc je pense qu'il ya une façon
effectivement émotionnel de regarder un
jeu dont les règles sont pas très
compliqué et sont à la portée d'un
enfant de 4 ans d'après ce que j'ai
compris
donc franchement je pense qu'il peut y
avoir du plaisir à regarder une partie
même quand on est un amateur même même
un piètre joueur et c'est ça qui fait la
comparaison justement avec équité et
qu'il nous nous nous fait croire que ce
média vava va exister va il va bien
marcher voulait intervenir
oui non je pense que c'est à peu près le
même avis je pense qu'un match de foot
on n'est pas très peu de gens excepté
les sportifs de haut niveau sont
compétents pour pour savoir si les les
footballeurs sont comment dire son forme
les conduire les petites astuces
techniques physiques et tout je pense
que c'est un jeu qui est aussi le fin
c'est un sport qui est aussi compliquée
que les échecs et que ce qui est
intéressant c'est de voir finalement
l'atmosphère qui se passe dans un match
de foot ou ou là les physiques les
conduire les expressions des joueurs et
aux échecs c'est exactement la même
chose quand on a une partie d'échecs
ce qui est intéressant c'est de voir les
pieds qui bouche la table les nerfs les
le visage l'attitude du joueur
kasparov par exemple c'est le roi de la
grimace le dire donc et en plus quand on
joue contre kasparov on a un show en
live que le dire d'ailleurs beaucoup de
gens s'en plaignent actuellement aussi
et loire oui effectivement je pense que
on est tous d'accord sur le fait que
même si on comprend rien au jeu c'est
difficile mais de toute façon si on
vient c'est qu'on a on a quelque chose
qui nous a amenés ici on va pas voir un
match de foot si on n'aime pas le foot
donc ici c'est pareil je pense que le
public qui vient connaît déjà un petit
peu le jeu d'échecs apprécié en tout cas
le jeu d'échecs et dans ces tournois
spectacle c'est quand même autre chose
que cette partie de six heures ici au
bout de deux mi-temps de 25 minutes
enfin 50 minutes chacun on a un gagnant
et un perdant c'est une sorte c'est un
match avec résultats il n'y a pas de
match nul c'est comme et ça ça je trouve
ça je trouve ça bien et ça crée des
tensions et donc dans ces échecs
spectacle au chaos on va dire il ya un
gagnant et perdant une élimination
et ça ça crée un climat autour autour
qui est un enjeu supplémentaire
m'écouter messieurs merci merci mesdames
mesdemoiselles messieurs nous pensons
bien sûr très fort à stéphane laborde
il doit penser à nous aussi bonne chance
et bon grand prix bordeaux 2000 à une
prochaine fois
alors une petite précision vous allez
être obligé de sortir pour des raisons
pratiques
même ceux qui doivent rester fa qui
souhaitent assister aux compétitions
après qui démarreront dans dans un quart
d'heure vingt minutes mais vous êtes
obligé de sortir et vous reviendra après
voilà merci bonsoir